I propose we get started we've got lots
that we want to
today this is a tweet that
yesterday from research group at UMass
and I thought this is a nice bridge
between last week and today so last week
we talked a lot about hyper parameter
tuning and kind of very expensive
testing regimes that the field has moved
toward in the era of deep learning and I
kind of preached a pragmatic approach to
all of this where you balance your own
budget in terms of money and time and
resources and everything else when you
design your experimental paradigm and I
thought inevitably you're gonna have to
compromise and the real thing that you
want to do in the paper is just be
upfront about where you had to
compromise which just means being open
and honest about your experimental
regime one ingredient one factor that I
didn't include in that discussion but I
think I will for future years is just
the environmental concerns that we might
have around very ambitious hyper
parameter tuning regimes and that's what
this paper is about I haven't seen the
paper itself that this seems to be one
of the core tables from the paper and
these numbers are quite shocking right
so you've got along this column here co2
emissions and I guess for some baseline
things it gives you like air travel
human life average and then American
life average that already is a kind of
shocking statistic their car lifetime
and then down here and this is kind of
striking because I mean training a
state-of-the-art NLP model for tagging
it's 13 co2 but with experimentation
that number jumps up to almost one year
for the average American in terms of co2
emissions and we're gonna this the
reason this is a nice bridge is we're
going to talk about the transformer
today among other things and again kind
of a modest but eye opening amount of
energy consumed for the transformer
large but once you start to do hyper
parameter optimization you're talking
about more than 10 years of average
American life co2 emissions to do this
hyper parameter optimization this is a
kind of environment environmental
disaster right are you interested in
deep learning for NLP but also concerned
about the co2 footprint of training you
should be yeah I really think this is
this is food for thought and frankly
I think this should be part of our
thinking about the kinds of experiments
that we run and where we invest our
resources so I don't know encourage you
to check out this paper once it's
available onto the transformer I guess
if I'm successful in my lecture today it
will be a environmental disaster I'll go
forth and train large transformers so
what we want to do for the first part of
class today until probably about 5:30 is
talk about contextual word
representations and then Cindy is going
to take over and do a mini lecture on
practical approaches to dealing with
very long text learning dense
representations of long texts
essentially which I think could be
useful for a lot of your projects so
it's well times but contextual word
representations I do think this is one
of the exciting things that happened in
recent times in NLP I'm going to try to
motivate that I'll do a little bit of
like guided in high-level insights about
why I think this is a wonderful
development in addition to all the
practical gains that it's led to on a
wide variety of tasks that's kind of the
core idea behind this contextual word
representations and then we're going to
talk about three approaches to learning
such representations Elmo the
transformer and Bert and then the final
section which we might just leave for
your own self study just introduces you
to that notebook that I posted at the
start of the quarter which shows you
some easy and practical ways that you
could bring Elmo and Bert into your
project even without having to do a
complete code overhaul so that your
embedded in their PI torch or tensorflow
code there's a bunch of associated
notebook so in addition to contextual
reps time the notebook there's also
Smith to 2019 which is a nice overview
paper that kind of does more of
providing high-level insights about how
we move from word vectors to contextual
word representations but also kind of
the guiding linguistic and empirical
ideas behind this whole movement I also
wanted to call out that the cs2 2 for n
lectures on these topics are really good
and they are somewhat different from my
lecture so they they offer much more of
the history and many more connections
with different tasks whereas given my
limited time
I've decided that I'm gonna try to just
convey to you how these models work and
with luck we'll get a sense not only for
how they work but also kind of why they
work and this is perfectly timed because
as you'll see we're going to build on a
lot of stuff that we've already done
it's like we're assembling raw materials
in a really creative and interesting way
to achieve some big gains and then for
Elmo transformer and Burt I just
mentioned here the core papers and also
the project sites which have code and
also pre trained representations
available for them and in that context I
thought I would call out especially this
wonderful kind of notebook paper called
the annotated transformer by Alexander
Rush who's on the faculty at Harvard
it's the actual transformer paper so
verbatim copy with a few comments from
him but woven into the paper is PI torch
code really nice efficiently written
clear PI torch code for every one of the
technical concepts so that by the end he
has fully implemented the model and also
tested it in a bunch of ways and I just
think that I mean what a wonderful kind
of contribution to make it's like with
all due respect to the original authors
of the paper and it's quite a nice paper
this is strictly better like the
combination of Alexander Rush plus that
original author team is strictly more
valuable because it saves you from this
thing that I experience all the time in
reading NLP papers that like I can't
quite tell from the language how the
pieces fit together or what the
dimensionalities of things are and I
can't quite do the matrix
multiplications in my head and then I
screw them up when I try them with pad
and paper there it's just all there in
code like every single ambiguity is
fully resolved there so hats off to him
and I encourage that as a way to study
what's happening in the transformer
paper and I also frankly encourage you
to do these things yourself because not
only is it a wonderful contribution but
I would say there's no better way to
deeply learn a paper than to do
something like this quite an achievement
let's move to the high level motivation
as I see it kind of with my linguist hat
on so I'm just going to show you some
examples here this is just around the
verb break the vase broke dawn broke the
Jews broke sandi broke the world record
sandi broke the law the burglar broke
into the house the newscaster broke into
the movie broadcast and we broke even so
they all involve a word form that sounds
like break I don't know how many word
senses there are here right in the sense
that I don't know whether we're dealing
with 11 different lexical items or two
or six or what I kind of have the
feeling and looking at paradigms like
this that the linguist notion that we
can cut up the world into different word
senses fully differentiate them is
breaking down the nature is not quite
cut up in that way it feels like we're
drawing on a bunch of metaphorical
connections and linguistic connections
that are being shaped by the
morphosyntactic Virant
environment in which this verb is being
used together with like its particles
and what we know about the world I think
a lot of these sentences are strictly
speaking ambiguous in some sense and we
perceive one reading but not others
because of what we know about the world
and on and on that feels like the real
picture of what's happening with the
verb break in this paradigm here are a
few more flat tire flat beer flat note
flat surface or throw a party a fight a
ball a fit
how many senses of the verb flat are in
to a or throw into B I don't know are
they even related are there for lexical
items or two or one I have no answer to
this question but I can tell that the
sense of these verbs is pretty well
cut-up once I put it in a particular
morphosyntactic context and bringing
kind of world knowledge about what I
expect the readings to be and all of
this I think points towards contextual
representations as the right way to go
because if you think back to the first
unit of this course where we represented
words in isolation as vectors what are
we going to do for one we're gonna have
to smush together all of those senses
into a single vector or we're gonna have
to do the really hard work of kind of
breaking up this break into a bunch of
different vectors and I think that
neither of those is going to work out
and moreover even if it did work out we
have this kind of average or static
representation
what we know from these examples is that
that vector ought to be influenced by
the context in that it's sitting in
alright that's our intuition that the
vase broke means what it means or dawn
broke means what it means because of
other words that are interacting with
this verb break here are some more
examples and these are subtly different
so I caught a crane caught a fish
you probably Intuit that that's a bird a
crane picked up the steel beam you
probably Intuit that that's a machine
and for I saw a crane you might just be
uncertain about what kind of crane it is
bird or machine I think that for 3a and
3b there are readings where a machine
catches a fish or a bird picks up a beam
but they're just highly unlikely given
what we know about world knowledge but I
don't want to lose sight of the fact
that you were steered toward one reading
or another because of this syntactic
environment the semantic environment and
also what you know about the world all
of that is shaping the scent of the word
sense for crane here and maybe less
shaped by 3c and then I think we could
extend this to examples that I showed
you when we talk about discourse and
dialogue so are there typos I didn't see
any think about the sense of any there
at the end it's shaped by the preceding
discourse are there bookstores downtown
I didn't see any same sentence but the
sense of that entire sentence and
especially any I think there and maybe
it's elliptical content is being shaped
by the preceding environment and all of
this points to the idea that static word
vectors are just not the way to go this
is what I was reflecting on this like if
you plucked your average theoretical
linguist off the street and tried to
convince them that words could be
represented as vectors of real numbers I
think it would be tough going but I
think after a little while you could
convince them that this is a smart way
to go and in fact it's quite close to
what they think about when they think
about word meanings as kind of very high
dimensional objects with lots of
relationships right like if you think
about word net you could represent those
things as vectors and kind of you're not
very far from what linguists are already
doing but I think once you convince the
linguist of that they would say wait a
second are these vectors just for words
in isolation and that's where you would
lose them because many linguists think
that word senses are kind of
shaped by their morphosyntactic
environment and then if you talk to them
about usage they would say well that's
going to be shaped by the whole
discourse context and everything else
and that's where your idea that words
could just be single vectors you'd never
convince them of that and that too I
think
Elmo Burt I think you could get them on
board with that that view of meaning so
the interesting twist there's of course
lots of empirical motivation that I've
kind of left out of the slideshow
because you can find those tables in the
papers and all over the web it truly is
a breakthrough on lots of tasks you
might have experienced this yourselves I
think some of our bake-off winds Trace
to Burt and Elmo and things like that so
you guys know about that picture so I
thought I would fill in kind of this
linguistic one here another perspective
that I thought we might think about here
just by way of high-level motivation is
kind of this notion of model structure
linguistic structure and the biases that
these are encoding all right so this is
like up here for example the ROC rules
where I just take all the vectors for
those words those could be like gloves
so isolated vectors and maybe some them
or averaged them to get a representation
of the whole sentence that model is very
high bias in the sense that it's making
a lot of presumptions about how word
meanings will interact to form a meaning
for the whole because you basically
hard-code right and anything that
deviates from glove and some is going to
be out of step with your model over here
on the right we have a model that's less
biased in the sense that you can learn a
very freeform function for combining
these three meanings into a whole
meaning for the sentence we've imposed
linear structure but if it turns out
that the linear structure ought to be
just the sum function is on the left we
can learn that but we could of course
learn lots of other functions and one
thing that we're doing in terms of bias
is creating a bias for a kind of linear
flow through the sentence which is
pretty natural if you think about
sentence processing but it is a
substantive thing to say about how to
represent the meanings and then down on
the left here you do that in a different
way so here the bias is that there is
tree structure that the rock forms a
unit
way that rock rules does not and that
the composition ought to proceed kind of
from bottom up paying attention to what
the linguist called the constituency of
this example very high bias right if
we're wrong about this tree structure we
might be in real trouble in terms of
what the model is going to do if we're
right about the tree structure this
could be a huge gain in terms of telling
the model how to combine things and what
to pay attention to so these are all
kind of very high bias and then if we
take this RNN here and run it by
directionally and we add a bunch of
these attention mechanisms that we're
going to talk a lot about today that is
pretty far along the spectrum to being
unbiased about what kind of interactions
we're going to see no more presumption
of left-right because we're going to go
in both directions and then not not only
that but we're gonna have all these
attention mechanisms that are kind of
allow us to leap around in the sentence
if that's what the data tell us to do
essentially and that's kind of very
freeform and I would say that all the
models that we talked about today are in
this category pushing in the direction
of assuming that we don't know anything
about what this data is going to be like
but we know they're going to be kind of
lots of dependencies that we need to
learn so let's just learn them in a very
freeform way give the model as much
capacity to learn them from data and not
bias it in any one particular direction
and I think like of the models we look
at today Bert is the farthest along on
this continuum Bert in the transformer
okay a few more things by way of setting
the stage because I did want to impress
upon you that you kind of already have
all the raw ingredients for all of these
models they're incredibly complicated
because there's like tons of stuff
happening in them but at their core
these are things that are familiar to
you so one team will be attention you'll
see this in the transformer and invert
and so I thought I'd just remind you
that we talked about attention here is
an N Li example every dog danced some
poodle danced you have all those word
representations down here and then these
hidden States for an R and n for the
premise and an RNN for the hypothesis
and the state to watch is h c up here in
the simplest form of global attention
that we considered what i do is
calculate a dot product
score by multiplying this vector by all
the vectors in the premise that's what
happens here
those get normalized via softmax
function and those scores then down here
are used to weight everything in the
premise and in the standard approach we
take the mean so this kappa here is a
vector that kind of summarizes
everything that was in the premise as
weighted by attention and then you
combine that into the classifier so that
the ultimate classification decision
here this hidden representation is Kappa
and this final state over here
multiplied through some weights there's
a couple ways you can do that and then
finally you get the classifier on top of
that hidden state remember that
simplest form of global attention with
dot products and the thing to keep in
mind is the core mechanism which we
applied just for the final state looking
back at all the premise states when we
get to the transformer you're going to
see this all over the place that's the
idea but it's exactly the same
calculation I'll try to call that out
another thing that we haven't really
talked about a lot since the first unit
is this notion of sub word modeling it
came up in the first unit because we
built these vector spaces and I think
some of you saw that if you kind of
broke them down into the character level
and then built up representations that
way you could make up for some of the
deficiencies in the original space by
kind of taking advantage of strength and
information that's shared across the sub
parts of words in the papers that we'll
look at especially ELMO that's done in a
somewhat more sophisticated way so I
thought I would just introduce this
impressionistic we and that lets you go
off and study it in more detail on your
own so starting down here at the bottom
I just have the word rules operating at
the character level I'm assuming that we
learn embeddings for each one of the
characters just like you would for words
but now things get interesting so what
I've tried to signal here are a bunch of
convolutional filters this is not an
idea that we've talked about in this
class they're not so common in NLP but
they're used by the ELMO team to get
word representations so the idea here is
I have a bunch of filters like this is a
filter of length one this is of length
two and this is of length three and what
the line signal is
doing a kind of moving window across
this example and I get representations
via a dense layer that connects the
characters that I'm connecting up into
this representation and then those are
combined via what's often called max
pooling so take this top one here which
had a window of three if these are the
vectors that I formed at each one of
those steps the max pooling
representation is just taking all the
max values from all three of the
different vectors to form a final
representation for convolutions in
general this could be the mean or the
sum or some other operation like that
but max pooling is common and that's
what the ELMO team uses and then to get
a representation for the entire sentence
you just piece together all the
representations that you got from max
pooling or through all of those filters
so you get something that looks like
this where like this would be the part
that goes to this first filter blue for
the second and green for the third and
that's kind of at the lowest level how
the ELMO team starts to represent words
they actually add a few more layers as
you'll see but I thought I would call
this out as a separate contribution
because this is one approach to kind of
gathering strength from the parts of
words the transformer does this in a
somewhat different way and that's this
next idea which again we haven't
discussed but I think this will be
really intuitive for you so part of what
you do for the transformer and for Burt
is have what's called positional
encodings and I've signaled that here so
I have word vectors the rock and rules
and they have their usual embeddings but
in addition I'm going to learn a
separate embedding space for different
positions in the sentence
that's what's signaled by this dark red
here 1 2 3 they each have their own
vector representations and then it's
common to just sum the positional vector
and the word vector to get a
representation of the word that is
context-sensitive that knows what
position it was in in the linear flow
and you could learn those
representations but a nice idea that's
kind of very free that comes from the
transformer paper is that instead of
learning them you might just construct
them to encode some positional
formation so what they do is do this
kind of sinusoidal thing where the
position is correlated with the
periodicity of these waves and that
means that you could generate them for
basically any length that you want it so
that if you saw a length at test time
that you'd never seen in training you
could generate the positional vector for
it sumit with your word vector and you'd
be able to do something useful whereas
if it's a learned embedding space you're
kind of stuck with what you've seen
during training in terms of example
lengths so this is a nice freeform idea
that you could apply anywhere if you fit
one of those sum of vectors classifiers
you might have positional encoding as a
way of infusing them with a little bit
of word order information and that would
be very easy to test out experimentally
and might really give you gains because
of this added sensitivity to position
that your model would then have yeah I
think the positional and codings would
be the same but the word vectors would
be different and that's how you'd get
both commonality between the first words
of those two sentences but also a
difference and you might do something
different yet again if it was like an N
Li pair where you might want to be
sensitive to position within the example
as well as position across the premise
and hypothesis you'll see that they do
that for bird yeah to clarify you take
the sinusoid as weight and do you
convolve that with the vector dimension
yeah they have a procedure for
generating these vectors that follow
these sinusoidal curves that are
sensitive you can see it's like dim four
five six and seven and I think four is
the one with the laziest pattern you add
it to your word vector that's what's
happening up here and that's the way of
encoding in a high dimensional vector
the position that you're in yeah
addition it always feels to me weird
that you add two vectors because it
seems
you just kind of gobble up both of them
like why not concatenate or is it just
purely empirical I think it's a good
question throughout all these papers
it's some I think it keeps the
dimensionalities low and allows some
freedom in terms of how you're combining
different pieces in these networks but
yeah I kind of and I would for if I was
trying this just as a you know taking a
simple model and adding positional
encoding I would try both some and
concatenation because it sure seems like
concatenation would be just as good if
not better assuming that I didn't have
to worry about dimensionality stuff
those are the high-level ideas let's
dive into these models a little bit and
again I think that this can't be a
substitute for reading the papers I
think you should think of this more as a
kind of guided tour that might help you
as you work through them but there's no
substitute for that you know hours spent
banging your head against these papers
and reflecting on them well let's start
him with Elmo because I think this
builds the most on stuff that we've
already done this is a pretty simple
idea that I think they just executed on
beautifully so for Elmo the ideas down
here I have my standard example the ROC
rules with a start symbol and each one
of them has a standard embedding but now
I'm going to transfer that into two rnns
one traveling forward and one traveling
reverse that's kind of orange and green
here so standard RN ends of the sort
you've seen before they use I think LST
M sells the paper I think it's deeper
than this network I forget the details
I've shown you just two layers but
obviously you can imagine that this
could be as deep as you wanted and then
once I've got those to earn our aren't
ends running for the classification
decisions that are going to produce the
next token I share parameters so up here
are shared parameters down here shared
parameters and these two are separate RN
ends with their own parameters to allow
them to run in both directions without
any masking or anything like that does
that make sense yeah our language models
that are trying to predict the
underlying sentence yeah so if you
follow just this left one here you do
the start symbol you hope it produces
as its prediction and then the next one
that gets inserted here and you hope it
produces ROC and so forth and then over
here it's just going to run in the
reverse direction doing those same
predictions and I think the other
important thing that seems meaningful
they point this out in the paper is that
there are shared parameters for the map
that takes you from the embedding into
the RNN and then shared parameters that
take you into the softmax layer then for
actual word representations conceptual
contextual word representations like if
I want to represent rules here that word
the final word then I can do that by
combining its embedding and can get
concatenating the two hidden states that
go along with it for each of these RN
ends so it's like these are the two
states that I drew from here and from
here and I drew these two states from
here and from here they get concatenated
and then part of ELMO learning when you
apply this to another task is learning a
task specific waiting on those vectors
so these are softmax normalized scores
that you can learn from data that tell
you how to weight the various levels
that you've learned from the core ELMO
model those all get some together after
the weighting and then I have this
single representation up here in yellow
which represents rules but notice it
represents rules not on its own but
rather from all the surrounding
morphosyntactic context so rules will be
different if the preceding words are
different for and from another example I
mentioned before that they do some other
tricky stuff in terms of representing
words and this is going to draw directly
on that convolutional stuff that I
reviewed before so imagine I want to
represent just some anonymous word up
here the way they build that up is first
at the character level that's down at
the bottom and then they have a bunch of
these convolutional filters like up to
seven of varying lengths those get
combined via max pooling in the way that
I showed you before and all those
representations from all the different
filters get concatenated into what's a
quite a wide representation
at this point and then they have what
they call highway layers which is a
separately developed machine learning
intuition about how essentially you can
learn some gating information across
different layers in a deep network so
like in the extreme case you could
actually learn parameters that would
tell you to skip a layer and just pass
up the lower representation but the
actual highway layer idea is more
flexible it allows you to learn
essentially gating information that will
tell you what percentage to allow to
pass on and what percentage not that's
what I've put in yellow here they're
just more dense representations that
function as these gates yeah sort of
different than the lsdm version it's
trying to it's from one of the same
authors the developers of LST ms and it
draws on a very similar intuition just
now applied in potentially very deep
layers the ELMO layers are only only two
is their max but I think the idea is
experimentally you could have like 25
layers and you would learn how to skip
around in that space and then finally
they do a dimensionality reduction down
to get the final word representation and
you might be able to tell from back here
that you're kind of constrained the word
representation has to be double the
length of the two hidden states so that
I can do this summing and that kind of
adds some constraints to this model and
that's why you have this final
projection layer because these are of
much higher dimensionality than you'd
want to accommodate for the rest of the
ELMO model but finally that gives you
your word representation up here and
that's what gets passed into the two RN
ends and then here's some information
about the models that they released
small medium original and the original
trained on much more data than this
simple original one here it shows you
the parameter counts the hidden sizes
for these networks some information this
is both LST M information and then the
number of highway layers in the word
representations that's a kind of summary
of how big these models get and one tip
I have for you if you want to know even
or about how they're set up the way
Allen NLP works is you have these
options files which more or less set up
the hyper parameters to the model and so
you can just look at them at the website
and see which activation functions were
used what the dimensionalities of
everything were what the filters were
like and so forth which is a even deeper
dive on the kind of mechanics of the
specific models that they released and
that's Elmo or any questions about Elmo
before I move on I understand how if
you're trying to predict a word from one
item that you've seen from the other one
they are trained separately and that
gets them around this problem which
you'll see come up when we talk about
the Transformers and Burt that you can't
have these things run in both directions
without doing some masking otherwise
words kind of see themselves so I think
imagine that these are n ends are being
trained separately against what might as
well be separate output states I just
drew them this way as a kind of reminder
that the parameters are shared that it's
kind of doing this multitask learning
from the same data just really talking
like you take the effective
representation and instead of doing all
this fastest you just kind of know that
you could just get straight back out
what you put back in wait did they block
out words what is it that makes this
task ultimately hard for the RN Angelo
well I think each of these RNs is doing
the hard task of language modeling so it
doesn't have those kind of degenerate
solutions it's just as hard as that task
is it's just that you have tied
parameters up here
goal then is to use these
representations in another task great
yeah in the context of the paper the
idea that they're really pitching is
that I can learn tasks tasks specific
word representations that could be the
input to another model so in the
simplest case and this is kind of what
you see in my notebook I have these
contextual word representations they
could be input to a further RNN that's
about your task trained against your
labels and then you're just benefiting
from all this other stuff ultimately
going down to the web scale data that
these representations were trained on
actual end task performance and
propagating that back onto your RN ends
or we trim the RN ends and we freeze
them and then we use them on our actual
tasks oh this is a good question I I
guess I assumed that the task specific
learning the fine-tuning that you did
was just on this softmax normalized
weights here but there's no reason in
principle why you couldn't have that
propagate down further to the ELMO
parameters themselves now I'd have to
check to see what's normally done do you
propagate all the way down anyone know
or just these weights here both of them
make sense as far as I can tell it's a
good question I think what you might
have in mind though is that for
transformers in Beart in principle we
can propagate down to all the weights as
part of part of fine-tuning let's skip
to that now so the transformer again
okay so let's build up this core model
structure there's a lot here and I just
want to kind of make sure I highlight
what I think are the really innovative
ideas and how they come together so
first down at the bottom this will be
familiar because what I've done is for
our example The Rock rules positional
encoding exactly the way I showed you
before and they don't learn these
embeddings in the paper they'd rather do
them in that kind of sine wave based way
so that they can generalize to example
lengths that they didn't see in training
which i think is a really nice idea but
they point out that you get very similar
results if you learn the embedding for
this Darkrai so those get summed and
that gives you the word
patience for the rock and rules and I
just wanted I'm going to call this out
with these equations here because
they're presented in a kind of nonlinear
way in the paper and I wanted to
organize them so see input is the sum of
these two vectors I'll concentrate on
the C but all of this is true for a and
B as well then the next layer is the one
where the real action lies this is where
the paper the title attention is all you
need comes from so to form the next
representation the ones I've got an
orange here you do that dot product
attention that I showed you before I
want to call out that that is exactly
what I showed you for the nli case with
the tweak that they do this
normalization by the lengths of the
representations which they find just
helps with scaling as learning proceeds
but other than that it's like the scores
softmax normalized on they happen to do
the sum in the paper of the weighted
other vectors it's called self attention
because instead of looking back from the
hypothesis into the premise now we're
just looking around when we're at sea we
look to be an A and Form attention
weights based on them and that's what
gives us this weighted view attention
weighted view of the input vector but
the mechanics are ones that are entire
entirely familiar as you can see here
know by the lengths of the
representations K here is the
dimensionality of everything that we're
going to see is we build up make sense
it's good so far self attention is just
attention all around me okay then we
keep building so then they have these
two kind of sub layer structure pieces
where to form what I've called a layer
here I sum the attention weighted
representation that I got here with a
drop out on the input and this is like
this is familiar to if you think back on
the attention lecture a lot of what we
do in attention is kind of take the
representation we care about and mix in
the attentional values and I take it
that that's what
happening here so the orange
representation is actually just this
kind of attentional thing on what's
around me it's not really a proper
representation of see so to mix them
together they do some and then the drop
out thing is just a bit of
regularization and that gives you see a
layer here in this yellow and I've tried
to draw this here this kind of sub layer
structure where it's kind of like you
elevate something below with something
that was an intermediate representation
and again that's done by some and that's
constraining the fact that all these
dimension these representations have to
have the same dimensionality then they
do layer normalization I think again
this is a kind of optimization trick
that helps the network to learn I've
given the calculations here this is a
kind of version of Z scoring where I
just kind of make sure that the vectors
for each of one of these layers are
scaled in a sensible way then you get
two layers of a feed-forward network the
first with a rail you activation
function in the paper but this is like a
kind of similar thing where this a this
norm this value here is here multiplied
by some weights and a bias that gets a
nonlinear activation and then another
dense layer over here and that gives you
what I've called cff in blue and then
want to again one of these sub layer
tricks so take C a norm and kind of
elevate it and combine it with C F F
having done some drop out on C F F and
that gives you C F F layer this is the
kind of darker or lighter yellow up here
it's kind of similar to this yellow down
at this point that's why I gave them the
same color same trick it's just that
here where we steered around attention
now we steer around the dense
representation and then finally a
normalization step same one as the one
we showed you before and that's the
output of this block of the transformer
as a mouthful any questions about it
DK is gonna be seven layers no no DK
would be like whatever we picked here
like 50 for the green and that right
yeah we're betting an additional bet I
think it follows from this network
structure that every single one of these
representations from the gray on up has
to have the same dimensionality because
here I sum so these have to be the same
here I sum here I sum I don't see any
space for kind of growth and shrinkage
so if we pick 50 down here it's 50 all
the way up and then this normalization
is the square root of 50 I hope I have
that right yeah all these sums at least
simplify some of these design choices
because it's at least you don't have to
do tuning over the dimensionality of
each one of these things and it's only
gonna get worse if you've read the
transformer paper you know that I've
just started here there's two more ways
in this net one in which this network is
going to get bigger and the first is
what's called multi-headed attention
this isn't going to be anything new it's
just we're going to do what we did
before a lot more okay so start with our
example and load follow the green here
so what we'll do is map this into its
own attentional space and the reason
that's meaningful is that this is that
attention calculation before but now we
have parameters w1 q w1 k and w1 v that
are particular to this head of the
multi-headed attention that we're
building but it's the same calculation
it's just that each one of the
representation is fed through these
dense layers so we do that call that H 1
that gives us 3 vectors over here and
then you do it you start to build that
up do it for H 2 as well same
calculation except now it's W 2 for all
three of those W's and that gives us
these representations do it for W 3 same
calculation but new parameters and so
forth all the way up to what they do in
the paper is 8 I think so they have 8
heads for these attention
lairs what they do is like if I picked
800 as my dimensionality the kind of
conceptual dimensionality for my
transformer network then each one of
these would have dimension 100 so that
the overall network didn't grow what
they're trying to do is kind of provide
more ways of ensuring that you have lots
of parameters to lots of interactions
and avoid kind of I think the network
ossifying in certain ways right really
flexibly learning how to map into this
attentional representation make sense
and then the final thing here is that
there is not just one transformer block
in the paper there are six so six
repetitions of everything that I have in
gray and I've just reminded you here
that we do multi-headed attention at the
bottom of each one of these layers and
then repeat the whole calculation the
eight can be done in parallel a huge
advantage of the transformer over like
RN ends is that a lot of this stuff can
be parallelized which leads to real
speed gains and that's one of the
advertising points for the paper in
addition to kind of being very freeform
and unbiased about how you learn how
words interact with each other you get a
lot of optimization gains with this and
I think that's why this network can be
so massive and still train in reasonable
times yeah well I drew it in a way that
was trying to reveal which parameters
were shared versus worth which were
split up but I might as well have copied
all these inputs and just had a bunch of
different attention things and that kind
of reveals to you the independence of
these calculations and then if you think
about gradient information flowing back
you know it's all going to be kind of
independent and just brought together in
the end I think that's why you can think
of these as separate calculations
so now I feel like having done that I at
least am in a position to understand the
diagram in the paper which I absolutely
did not understand the first time I read
the paper but now I kind of get it so
the left side is of course repeated for
every state in the encoder they've only
shown one state for compact nests but
like the ROC rules would be three
repetitions of this each decoder state
self attends with all the decoder states
and with all the encoder states that's
something that I didn't quite confront
in my core discussion but just imagine
everything that I was doing on our
single example if we were doing like a
dialogue agent or summarization or
translation all the decoder states were
like in n Li the hypothesis could attend
back to everything in the premise as
well as attending to all things that
were that were in their own space so
that's what this line is meant to signal
here self attention in both sides and
also attention backwards the right side
of course repeated for every decoder
state yeah I think that's all I have to
say there and then finally just wanted
to point out this is a complexity and
I'm not going to talk about but in the
decoder self attention is limited to
preceding words so that words can't kind
of see themselves so there's a bunch of
masking that has to happen in order for
us to do this on the decoder side but
for things like n Li you don't have to
confront this because you're just trying
to predict a label and you can attend
everywhere if you want yeah that's it
for the transformer questions about the
transformer great so now Burt this will
be comparatively easy if you have the
transformer in mind because it's obvious
call bi-directional encode
representations from transformers
okay once more we build up a model down
here I have the rock rules you have a
special class token that Bert has and
it's got its own embedding and then the
three familiar tokens they all have
positional embeddings just as before and
now they also have a sentence level
embedding which is just repeated in this
example in dark red and the idea there
is that if I've got a two example thing
like premise and hypothesis then I have
two embeddings one for the first one for
the second so each word is infused with
that high level positional information
but again it's just summing those
representations to get the Green
embedding here which you might think of
as the token representation and then you
just do a bunch of transformer stuff
right and the important thing I think to
signal there is that you do a bunch of
self attention on these representations
and that gets that flows into the
transformer and then once you've done
all the self attention stuff it's that
kind of norming and drop out and sub
layer structure with a feed-forward
network at a certain point you know that
mixture of ideas but surely the
important thing here is that at the
start of each one of these transformer
blocks we do all of this attention all
around us right so it's not an RNN and
it's not a back and forth RNN it's more
like this dense thicket of connections
that we can make to form those initial
representations and you can repeat the
transformer blocks I think they do too
in the paper so it's not as deep as the
transformer but some number of them get
repeated and then to use this model to
make predictions since it is flowing in
both directions you can't just do a
standard language modeling task so what
they do instead is a test they call
masked language modeling so in this case
you just make predictions about certain
words that have the mask value so just
block out an actual word and then learn
to predict the word that was there and
they do that on about 15% of the tokens
the rest are shown to the network and
that's the sense in which case
and trained against these missing points
and learn a bidirectional model without
any of those problems of words seeing
their own future and past so it's a kind
of standard language modeling thing just
trained in a really innovative way that
makes sense and then the other piece is
for doing transfer learning and fine
tuning the convention that they adopt in
the paper is that this class token here
is used as the summary representation of
the whole example and what that means is
that in the simplest case you could just
add a classifier on top of it the way we
did for nli for example where we took
the last state or the first and the last
States and use them for a classifier
here you just use this final transform a
representation associated with the class
label so that's the simple case of just
doing like transfer learning and then
they advocate doing a lot of fine-tuning
of the parameters so you put this
classifier on top and then not only do
you update the parameters for that
classifier but allow that gradient
information to flow throughout the
network and in that way all the burr
parameters potentially get updated for
your task and if you've done BIRT
fine-tuning I think you did that and
that's what the code that they released
makes very easy to do in addition to
that masked language language modeling
tasks they trained the network the one
of the parameters that they released
against a second prediction task which
is binary sentence prediction so for
this they can generate their own data
again just like they could by masking
out certain tokens here the positive
instances are actual sequences of
examples from their corpus like class
the man went to masks store set he
bought a gallon mask milk SEP and that's
labeled is next because those two
sentences did actually occur in a corpus
that they're learning from and then for
the negative examples they choose some
random second sentence and label that
not next and so then training proceeds
in the way that you would expect using
this class label here and you're
fine-tuning the whole
Network against this high-level next
sentence prediction task and so that's
the sense in which it's been jointly
trained against the language modeling
task and the sentence prediction task
and I guess that's like local coherence
and more global or discourse coherence
for the model so two notions of context
dependence which seems again really
right to me in terms of the what you'd
want and for learning representations a
funny and delightful twist about the
Bert code release and the Bert data
assets is that the vocabulary is tiny if
you download over a Bert model here I
did the uncased one from the small model
and just read in the vocabulary it's
only got thirty thousand tokens in it
thirty thousand word things in it and
you might think how on earth is Bert
gonna be so good at new text if it's got
this tiny little vocabulary and by
contrast I think the ELMO vocabulary is
like huge so this is a real puzzler how
is it going to do well that well with
only thirty thousand tokens well if you
look at those tokens as I've done here
you've got like folder that's a word but
then hey you know hash tag hash tag good
greed and principles then moving and
then this other funny word fragment and
then if you use their tokenizer which
you you know if you just download their
code and load it in the tokenizer here
then this isn't too surprising that does
a normal thing basically except it maybe
it's unusual about how it handles this
contraction but more or less this looks
like words but then if you say does Bert
know snuffleupagus which is another
Sesame Street character it breaks it
does not know that word that is not in
the vocabulary and so it breaks it up
into a huge number of smaller tokens
with those boundary symbols and those
boundary symbols tell the model that
it's word internal and the actual
tokenizer uses an underscore for
whitespace so no information is lost as
you do tokenization with this tool and
you get a whole lot of strength from sub
words so this is great and this also
shows you why you shouldn't do your own
token as
with Burt because you want to let it
kind of do its own divisions and use its
own proper embedding space but then Wow
talk about an efficient representation
of the vocabulary I would not have
guessed you just asked me two years ago
that this would be an effective thing to
do but wildly successful and then here's
some basic information about the models
they release so Burt base this is
manageable for your computer I mean its
large but you can work with it
oops I this should say large here this
is the large one this is truly enormous
and if you try to work with this on your
laptop everything might fall apart I
guess that's the lesson here and they
are limited to sequences of 512 tokens
that's the longest you can get because
that's how many positional embeddings
they learned which reminds me of the
transformer paper where they gave
themselves the flexibility to learn for
longer sequences that's Burt any
questions about Burt
lots of Transformers it's just mostly
the encoder part of the transformer
right it doesn't have the decoding part
that's kind of handled implicitly by the
way you're doing this multi like back
and forth approach I think that's
exactly right yeah drop the decoder it
was a hassle it was getting in the way
of being truly bi-directional and
instead changed to this light a masked
language modeling task yeah it's really
that's one of the shining insights of
the paper
yeah no it will learn to produce yeah if
you just mask out it will learn to it
will make predictions about those tokens
yeah okay I have a few minutes before I
wouldn't want to turn the tej over to
Cindy so I thought I would just point
out the guiding idea for that notebook
is whatever architecture you're
developing for your project it might
benefit from contextual word
representations speaking as a linguist I
would say surely it's going to because
these representations were trained on a
lot of data and they're very good
and whatever your problem is word order
and context matter so might as well try
to bring them in now it might be hard
for you to bring them in to whatever
codebase you're working with because
maybe you're using side kit or you're
using PI torch in your own way that
would get in the way of doing the fine
tuning that they advocate but don't let
that stop you because you could just use
the notebook tools to initialize your
network using these representations
that's a kind of twist on the standard
thing for R and ends right so for RN
ends usually we have this fixed
embedding space that makes that mistake
of not having context for its
representations and you just look up
your tokens get their indices and look
them up in the embedding and that
finally gives you the vector sequence
that the RN n is actually processing as
its inputs with these contextual
representations you just skip all those
intermediate steps and go directly from
your vocabulary to sequences of vectors
and now where as a and a year had to be
identical and B and B had to be
identical now they could be changed
depending on their context and that
might give your network a real head
start it's really easy to do this this
is a complete use of the SSD sentiment
framework its whole experimental
framework with Elmo and you turn you get
impressive results with Elmo if you
compare back to the baselines for this
ternary task for this um torch RNN big
boost and then for Bert similarly very
easy to bring these things in you've got
to do a little bit more careful
pre-processing of Bert vectors because
they are very large but still
straightforward to bring it into the
paradigm and then you're off and running
Bert is even better according to this
experimental run for these parameters so
I hope that's empowering any questions
about any of that yeah if you look at
the task of producing like let's say a
vector representation a single word in
context like I guess I'm wondering if
there's anything else like a next step
or that what would be the next challenge
to overcome as far as making these
representations
really predictive oh I don't know if you
have ideas that could lead to a major
contribution I mean now surely more
discourse sensitivity like going beyond
maybe the binary sentence task that's
something even higher level because I
think that all my word meetings are
being influenced by everything that's
happening in the discourse around us so
the more of that we can bring in the
better will be and if you could bring in
stuff like task sensitivity that would
be even better and on and on yeah you
know what why stop at linguistic context
the physical context matters gesture
matters visual salience matters bring
those things in maybe there's a Sesame
Street character out there waiting for
you all right good that was a giant gulp
from this very rich fountain of ideas
go forth and read the papers and let me
know if you have any questions I think
what I'll do now is turn it over to
Cindy for a related topic so this short
talk is just going to be about
representation learning for a long text
so so far in the course we've mostly
talked about kind of learning
distributed representations for words or
for sentences but like mostly limited to
sequences of a few words right if you
think about the assignments that we've
done for like word similarity or like an
ally or sentiment classification that's
kind of been capped out at sentences
that like just a single sentence right
so we haven't really thought past that
to a paragraph or even like a long
document but for some of your projects
you might be interested in doing on
these sorts of NLU tasks for longer
texts so we're going to talk about a
couple of ways that you can kind of get
the same distributed representation but
for something longer and so yeah so so
far you know like we've been doing
representation
the word or sentence level and this is
good because we can kind of get like a
vector that represents our input that we
can pass into a classifier or we can
compute distance using some distance
metric and those things are like very
useful and for a wide variety of NLU
tasks yeah but our goal for today is how
can we apply and all you methods like
the ones that we've been using two
longer attacks so for example news
articles scientific papers or even books
or like transcripts of conversations
things like that
so some example tasks that we might want
to do or like document classification so
for example if you have like the
transcript of a parole hearing and you
want to predict whether that transcript
you know ended up in a positive or
negative decision you might want to like
cluster documents together so for
example you have like hundreds of
different news articles and you want to
cluster together the ones that are
talking about the like same event or
concept maybe that's something that you
want to do or even reading comprehension
so if you're familiar with squad that's
a reading comprehension data set and
that kind of takes like a paragraph long
context and tries to find the answer and
within some span of that paragraph but
there are even reading comprehension
datasets that look at like you know
longer inputs so for example the news QA
data set takes an entire CNN article and
kind of does a similar thing to squad or
on you know you ask you a question and
try to find the answer somewhere within
the whole article so you can see how
that would be a significantly more
difficult task because you kind of have
to look across this much longer context
for the answer um then a final example
will be summarization or you know you
want to go from a very long text to a
shorter representation of the still
capturing all the meaning so yeah I just
want to talk about a couple of methods
that are like hopefully practically
useful for you guys on while you're
thinking about these things and like
working on your projects um so just to
start off I want to refresh
unlike director representations of words
we've seen a ton of different methods to
do this you know from the very basic
just using like one-hot representations
to represent a one word in your whole
vocabulary or to use some of these like
VSM type approaches or even from today
using something like bert or elmo to get
word representations right but kind of
like the question like when you want to
go from word vectors to something longer
it's like you know if i have vectors
that are representing like each of the
individual words and my input how can i
like kind of compose those into a
representation for my whole paragraph or
document so does anyone have any like
ideas of something that they would try
just you know as like maybe a bass line
or like something just off the top of
your head yeah yeah yeah so uh if people
didn't catch that it was just like take
all your word vectors and average them
and that's actually a really good
approach which is like you know often
done like not even as a bass line but
just like as the primary approach to get
like a document vector given a bunch of
word vectors right and especially if you
have like kind of context-aware
representations like bert vectors maybe
that's good enough yeah so that's like
the first good baseline method just to
do sort of like a bag of word vectors
sort of thing where you sum or average
or kind of do a max pool over the word
vectors in your paragraph or document
but can anyone think of like some
drawbacks to using this as like the only
thing to create your like document
embedding yeah a word in the first
sentence can be very different contexts
in the word of lessons yeah yeah
definitely you kind of lose like the
like the structure of the sentence or
like the ordering of the words yeah for
sure so a one kind of like you know step
above doing that is to instead of just
like do a pure
averaging to use like the structure of
the sentence itself you know to like do
these sort of like matrix operations but
in like a structured way so like you
know maybe you can parse your sentence
first and then combine the words based
on that parse tree that comes out and
that's also like a pretty good approach
but it does like rely on your person to
be accurate and doesn't work as well
once you have more than one sentence so
another thing that you might want to try
is like using an RNN as your document
encoder right so like something um that
you could potentially think of doing is
like training an RNN as an autoencoder
for the paragraph or document that you
have or even you know like having the
loss propagate all the way back from
whatever downstream tasks so like maybe
you're doing the classification and then
something that you could do is use the
output at the last time step as kind of
like an embedding for your whole
document and like we've seen this one
we're doing like sentence of headings
right I guess I already have this on the
slide here but what's kind of like you
know a situation where like doing this
would be like not the best solution I
mean maybe your most important
informations in the first sentence and
then you have a bunch of just kind of
filler information so if you use the
very last thing maybe you basically have
the vanishing gradient problem where all
of your signal has gotten diluted along
the way yeah that's exactly right so
especially for the cases that we're
thinking about now where you have a very
very long text if your document you know
is like many sentences long then like
and you're taking kind of output of the
last time step as your representation um
then yes exactly so through the
vanishing gradient problem you know a
lot of the signal from the beginning
gets lost and maybe that context from
the beginning is important right and
you'll like often in a lot of documents
the context from the beginning like for
example the abstract or like the first
sentence of an article like that's like
sending a lot of the signal for whatever
task you might want to do and so one
approach that was developed specifically
kind of for this task
of representing long text like document
length text is called dr. Beck and this
might look familiar because it's from
the authors of word Tyvek and so like to
kind of put this in context since the
dr. Beck algorithm is actually quite
close to the ones used for a word to
that I'm just do like I'll just do a
quick like brief review of kind of what
is going on when we do train word Tyvek
vectors so essentially we have kind of
like a sliding window over the current
word so here like the current word would
be jumped and our window like let's say
the length is five right so it's
including like this whole section of the
sentence and we're using the surrounding
words of our current word to try to
predict our current word and that's kind
of like the objective that we're
optimizing for and then through back
propagation this word embedding matrix
will get updated and then by the end of
training we'll have a matrix containing
vectors for all of the words in our
vocabulary each of which is like a
distributed representation of that word
and hopefully you know embeds some sort
of context information and like you know
is something that is semantically
meaningful and so going from word to
vector dr. Beck it's actually very very
similar so the only thing we're really
adding here is this extra vector that
gets combined with the words in our
context window which is the document
vector so in addition to our word
embedding matrix we also have a document
matrix which has you know like a row for
each document ID in our training corpus
and so when we are trying to predict the
kind of like Center word in our context
we're also incorporating the document
vector which you can kind of think of as
like a memory for like the concept of
the document overall so in this kind of
paradigm we're training this word
embedding matrix simultaneously with the
document matrix and you know you can get
like your document representation by
simply extracting a row from the
document matrix
does anyone have any questions about
that does that mean the top view is
going to be more influenced by the words
at the beginning of the document
like where and is it just does the doc
ID like is that a token that is
somewhere no so you couldn't kind of
just like think about it as a memory for
like the entire document as a whole so
like for each context window within the
whole document that document ID vector
will be incorporated appear like in the
middle position as the thing that you
were predicting other things relative to
or only kind of as in addition to the
context window oh like will it ever be
uh like in the middle of these oh I see
like will it ever be the thing that
we're trying to predict um according to
the paper no I guess I would be like an
interesting thing to try but no because
I could see how it would sort of allow
the word embeddings to cheat a little
bit not actually learn as much about the
language like even imagine that it could
just kind of gee guess that it's jumping
even though the sentence is not like you
could just like kind of be lucky and
always like predictive regardless of the
context um yeah that's possible and like
I think it's like one of the trade-offs
and so like so something that's commonly
done is like you might want to
initialize your word embedding matrix
with like some like word vectors that
are already pre trained and then you're
kind of like using this as more of like
a retrofitting sort of scheme yeah like
I think that that's definitely possible
but it might be like more of an edge
case because this way like one corner
you even get like better word embeddings
because you kind of have like both the
overall context of the document as well
as like the words that are trained
because even though these word
embeddings are like used for all of the
documents like you could think of the
representation for one word in one
document as kind of
like the combination of both the
document vector and the word vector so
this is sort of like the micro level of
words and then like the macro level of
documents but has there have been work
done on like doing some medium level
like the beginning middle and end of a
document however that's defined like the
first second and third I mean I don't
know work in this mode but there's all
the work on what was called text styling
and that was the unsupervised method for
discovering which parts of the document
were important and I think you might be
drawing on similar insights about maybe
learning them in a more freeform way and
I think the idea that Sydney is pointing
out here has enough generality that you
could do it at the paragraph level or
hierarchically right you could learn a
lot of these different inventing layers
yeah for the reporting people cool yeah
so trying to summarize the dr. Veck
approach simultaneously learns a word
vector for every word and also a
document vector for every document and
some of the benefits are that it's kind
of like this unsupervised training
paradigm so you can get good document
vectors without you know having to train
for some specific downstream tasks and
it's kind of like purely based on like
the word distributions I'm within your
corpus and then one thing that I didn't
talk about was what kind of happens at
inference time so like you know if you
use like the docs of that kind of
approach to get document vectors like
you know what happens when you have a
document that it wasn't part of your
original training corpus so like isn't
present in that document matrix so what
the paper actually proposes for
inference time is when we're trying to
do this we will fix the word matrix so
like those the word vectors are no
longer updated but will augment the
document matrix with this new document
and then actually like retrain for a few
epochs
to get the document vector for that new
document so a one potential issue with
this is that it's actually like
non-deterministic because of that kind
of pre-existing state like within the
model right so if you kind of do this
the like twice for the same like input
document you might actually get two
different vectors and like we can solve
this by just like training for more
epochs that'll make it a little bit more
stable but that is kind of a risk pool
and so just to wrap it up there here are
some good resources that you guys can
turn to if this is something that you're
tackling in your own project kind of
like you're doing something involving
long text that needs representations for
that so the Jensen package which with we
seen before with word two that provides
a very good doctor Veck implementation
that you can just kind of like use out
of the box so that's really helpful and
then for general document embedding the
flare library has like some good classes
that you can use to do like various
different types of embedding so you can
kind of have like a whole pipeline to
kind of extract you know like burn
embeddings and like word to vac and
betting's and then like combine them in
a variety of ways whether that be
through like you know simple pooling or
like also RNN methods so yeah if you
guys are working on something that is
using long texts it's like definitely
point you guys towards these resources
so hopefully it's helpful
[Applause]
any last questions though
if people tried using transformers for
this that's an exit question yeah so I
was talking with Chris earlier about
like how effective it would be to use
like transformers or like to even use
Burt as like an encoder for like a
document length like sort of input and
Burt for sure it kind of has like like a
length cutoff at least for the pre train
models the maximum sequence length
it's like 512 I believe so that could be
long enough for something that you want
but it might be too short so it kind of
just depends on your task
yeah you could do that yeah and then
kind of have to make a design decision
as to like how you want to combine the
representations for different sentences
but yeah I think like at the sentence
encoding level there's been a lot of
work done and there's like a whole
plethora of things yeah or just being
one of them only thing I would say for
that is that I feel that it's not in the
spirit of the burnt paper to sentence
tokenize but I feel like that should
come certainly you should just be
putting Sep symbols but learning
continuously as opposed to doing a kind
of card aggregation at each sentence so
I feel like even if bird is practically
useful in that setting
you know chunking my sentences there's
still an opportunity there to think
about applying it at the document level
but I think that would lead to a bunch
of obstacles right now not just because
it's appreciate representations but also
because of the amount of compute
well thank you again summed it up
straight
[Applause]